With Instacart, you get groceries that over-deliver. And with Instacart's in-store prices at select stores, you can do more this winter without paying more. So double down on your shortbread production without upping the price. Add more chilies to your chili without the added sting. Go completely ham on candy DMs and celebrate the season of being extra without paying extra. So download the app today and get $0 delivery fees on your first three orders. Instacart. Groceries that over-deliver.
Service fees, exclusions, and terms apply. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hello there.
Hi there. Oh there. Ah. This is nice. studio. This is our first in-studio recording since I went to Chicago. I know. It's been months, ladies. I know. I like being in real life with you. I know in the IRL life. Yes. I'm also really excited about today's episode. I am too because it's just joy. It's what it is. If you want a little bit of joy in your life, you're here. You're at the right spot. This is our fan appreciation episode.
We are going to share about getting to meet all of you at the office convention and at the stage door of Ashland Avenue. But before we do that, Angela, you said you have a special fan appreciation shout out. I really do. I'm so tickled by this. And the first shout out I want to goes to an office ladies fan that works on the television game show, Jeopardy. So here's the thing. Katie is her name, Katie Ruskus. She reached out. She is the office production assistant at Jeopardy. And she wanted to tell us that Office Ladies was going to be a question on Jeopardy. I can't believe it. And as I began to trade messages with her, I found out that her dad is a huge Office Ladies fan. Shout out to Chris, her dad. Hi, Chris. And her dad got Katie listening
to Office Ladies, and now they listen to it together. I love that. Is that adorable? Yes. Katie is such a delight. So the episode already came out. Yes. This aired on October 22nd. We have a clip. This is how we appear. on Jeopardy. Give it a listen. Television for 12. A podcast episode from Office Ladies debated whether or not this character in HR from the office was the Scranton Strangler. Tom. Who's Toby? Right. Isn't that so cool? Yes, I mean, that's really cool. I remember when I was the answer in one of the like people crossword puzzles. So fun. And now Jeopardy. I know. It's the big time. It's the big
time. Well, you know, my grandmother watched Jeopardy every day. And I just think she would have been so thrilled with this. And if that wasn't cool enough, the folks at Jeopardy sent us each a framed copy of our Jeopardy question and the day it aired. I have one for each of you guys. We'll get a picture and share it. But how fun. I love it. Well, thank you, Katie, and please thank your dad for listening to the podcast. Now we're going to get into some stories about the office fan convention. Yeah, you know what? This was a really fun road trip that Cassie and I took. It was this past August. It was the big, big, the office fan convention in New Jersey. Well, we should tell everyone that I couldn't go to the office fan convention because I was in Chicago rehearsing my play. But like you said, you and Cassie did go together. Yeah, it was Cassie's first The Office Convention. And everyone was so lovely. We got to meet a ton of people. And there were a lot of Office Ladies fans there.
Well, lady, I got to meet so many Office Ladies fans at the stage door for Ashland Avenue. Isn't it so fun? Because they say, lady, and you know right away. I do. If someone said Lady, I knew they listened to Office Ladies. But yeah, after each performance, I would come out. And so I think we had like 39 performances of Ashland Avenue, and I was able to come out 37 times. That's fantastic, because I've been to plays. People don't come out. I'm just saying. I know. That's really great. There were two I wasn't allowed to come out for. So if you were at those performances, I apologize.
They don't do a stage door after opening night because there's this special event immediately following and they want the cast and crew to get there quickly. And also one day after a matinee, a man fell down the stairs in the lobby and they had to call an ambulance and they had to clear the lobby so I wasn't allowed to come out. He's okay. Okay, good. But lady, I have to share a story because a few times, I was. was on vocal rest because my voice with eight shows a week, it was getting strained and I would have these big weekends with so many shows in a row. So they said, you can do the stage door, but you can't speak. And so they would send this gal Lauren out to the crowd. And she would explain that I was on
vocal rest, but if people got their cameras ready or if they had their pens ready, that I was going to come take pictures and sign things. And it was just very funny because every time I came out, normally I would come out the stage door and people would be like hey yay and it was so sweet they would cheer for every cast member who came out the stage door but if it was a vocal rest day when I opened the door people would go hi as if the crowd was also on vocal rest it's so cute and then when I would interact with people they would whisper as well or like mime it's such a natural thing that people do because even when I called you because you were like I can't talk but you can talk and I be like, hey. Yes. Like, what am I doing? I know, exactly. I can talk.
But that's just one story. I have so many stories. But lady, you start. Okay, well, that just warms my heart. Just picturing all those people out there waiting for you. You know, I also want to share that Josh and I met so many wonderful office ladies folks on our cookbook tour. I was so moved.
I was so moved that people traveled far distances just to support us and our dream of having a cookbook. And yeah, it was really special. one lady brought me a basket. Like a bag, you know, I love baskets. Oh, just because you love a basket. Nothing in it. Nothing in it.
Her name was Orla, and she was like, I support this passion of yours for baskets. But then guess what? We put a bunch of stuff in it. Of course you did. Anyway, I want to start right now with the office fan convention. Yes, I want to hear these stories. So, for one, for me, it was really special that Cassie got to go because Cassie and Sam are such a big part of our office ladies' family.
and so many people were so tickled when I was like, Cassie's here. They're like, Cassie? And then they were like, where's Sam? And they were like, we need Sam. Word is on the street, Sam, also that you like conventions. So they're ready for you to turn up at things. But for those of you that haven't been to a convention, I was trying to describe it to my sister. You know, that's where people go when you're fans of movies and TV shows and you can meet people
in the movies and there's all kinds of great merch. Oh my gosh, if you love merch. but this one was specifically just for the office fans. Like there weren't people from the Marvel movies or it's just the office community. And the energy was so profoundly positive and wonderful. I had a booth, you know, you have booths where people can wait in line to meet you. Mine was right next to Rain Wilson. We had a curtain between us and he kept opening the curtain and yelling things at me.
Like, do you talk too much? Speed it up. He was like, kind of like giving me shit all day. It was really funny. But you meet people from all over the United States and honestly, all over the world. And they share with you what the office has meant to them. And the day is kind of structured. So you have this line where you meet people. But then you also pop off and you go do photo ops with different configurations of the cast. And those are so fun. So you do a big group photo. But then they were like, okay, now one just with the accountants. So it would be me and Oscar and Brian. And then a fan as well? Yes, and then they pop in. Okay. And then it will say, okay, does anyone want a picture with Dwight and Angela? And so then we have all these Dwayangela fans, which shout out to my Dwayangela people.
And so you do that. And then you have a Q&A panel, and the whole cast gets up there and fans ask questions. Yes, yes. Lady, I sent in a video to play during that panel because I couldn't be there. And they edited it together. It was so cute. Well, shout out to Matt. from the Office Alliance. It's an Instagram account. That's all things the office. He really helped
put your video together. Yeah. People loved it. Yay. The minute you popped up on the screen, I wish I had video of the audience because they were like, yay, Jenna's here. Aw, I'm so glad. I always love doing the office panels. Like, I like those Q&As. I know. Yeah, they're really fun. People always have the best questions. But I do have to share one cute, fun moment from the Q&A panel. So a fan had asked a question about, you know, there's a moment where you got nervous on the show or something like that.
And I shared how I don't like to sing in front of people, you know. And then all of a sudden I had to sing the little drummer boy in front of the whole entire cast. Yes. And how I was really nervous. So I got up and Rain and I recreated the moment. You did. Yes.
And he dropped to his knee and did the pabra bum, the whole thing. It was so cute. Did people love it? People went nuts. I think there's video. of it that I'll share. Ugh. On Saturday of the convention,
over 7,000 people came. Is that amazing? That's a lot. A huge amount of the cast came and some of our crew. That's so amazing. What a fun experience. So not only do you have all of this
really great engagement between the cast of the office, the crew of the office, and fans that love the show, but these conventions are also an amazing opportunity for artists that love the office and do the office fan art,
including tattoo artists. Lady, you could get a tattoo at the convention. Wait, like a temporary tattoo or a permanent tattoo? No, a real tattoo. And they would be all office themes, like Save Bandit or a Prison Mike tattoo or a Dundee or a teapot or like a tattoo with Angela Martin that's like sassy. I mean, I met so many people that had office-inspired tattoos. They were amazing. I took a few pictures, but my favorite was this lady I met who had a tattoo on her calf.
of a train. And the train had a sign on it that says slow. And then next to the sign, it said, Philly, like you're coming into Philly, but you're on the slow train. Yes. It was so awesome. I'll put it in our stories. Well, lady, I know that you love seeing people's office tattoos. You often send me text messages of people you've met who have showed you their office tattoos. I mean, I find it so fascinating. People love the show that much. They get a tattoo. Well, when I met people at the stage door, if they showed me an office tattoo, I would ask if I could take a photo and then I sent them to you. You did.
I did have a favorite. Okay. I think it was someone that got the little hot dog that said, hi, you, buddy. Hi, you, buddy. Yes. But there was also a woman who had a whole arm, like a sleeve of all office tattoos. I took a video. I was like, would it be weird if I took a video of your arm so I can send it to Angela?
She was like, no, it was incredible. Well, Cassie was able to walk around to all the different booths. I was sort of, you know, a little bit stuck in my line. So I didn't get to explore quite as much. And she took a lot of pictures and videos. And Cassie is actually in here in the studio with us. And Cassie, you got to meet a lot of people and ask them about their love for the office and office ladies. And you compiled all these audio clips.
You spent a lot of time. It was really wonderful. We're going to share some of them today. But before we start playing them, I was wondering if you could tell us a little bit about your experience at the convention. Yeah, of course. It was so nice meeting all these, like, office ladies fans and office fans and, like, really feeling how passionate they are for the show and the podcast. And, yeah, I talked to so many people. I had, like, a little microphone.
You did. You had your own line. I looked over. And, like, I would meet people and then they'd go over and we'd be like, do you want to say hi to Cassie? I feel like almost everybody said yes. Yeah. Pretty much everyone did. So it was really hard to, like, pick my favorite clips because I loved them all.
But there is one that I think is a good to start with. Okay, great. Can we hear it, Sam? Cheryl and Elizabeth. Hi. From Connecticut. Nice. Yep. And what does the office mean to you?
Levity. And she brings Levity to the office every day now. Yeah, I literally am not allowed to say that's what she said anymore. Yeah. Wait, do you two work together? And we do it in her best friends. Oh, my God. That's so cool.
It's like the office and office ladies combined. Aw. Cheryl and Elizabeth. They're BFFs that work together. It's so sweet. I like that they have rules, though. You can't say that's what she's saying. The other clip I wanted to start off with is this clip from Julia, who is a huge office lady's fan.
Great. My name's Julia. And what are you wearing? So I've got my teapot earrings. I've got the pams. And then, of course, my podcast merch here, my scarf. Do you have a favorite office ladies episode or a moment? I love the big.
cruise episode where Greg Daniels talks about, you know, what are people saying they're doing versus what they're doing and how to catch that. You learned so much on the podcast. What does the office mean to you? The office is home, and I feel most like myself when I'm listening to the podcast on my Wednesday walk. Yay. Every time I hear when someone shares that they listen to the, you know, podcast on their walk or in their commute and just know that we feel that time for them and we're having.
happy place for them. I love it so much. I think it's so sweet that she was wearing so much of our merch, Angela, because you work so hard on it. I do love merch, and when I see anyone in an office lady's sweatshirt or anything, I do geek out. I always comment on it. Well, at the stage door, people would wear our merch and like the tattoos. If anybody was wearing our merch, I asked if I could take a picture and send it to you. One woman wore our office lady's apron. Our apron lady, That's traveling back in time. I know. I believe her name was Vera, and she also gave me some gooey butter cake from St. Louis.
So thank you, Vera. Well, why don't we take a break? And when we come back, we're going to share some more stories from the convention and the stage door, some really amazing fan encounters, including Cassie and I have a story for you about a couple that got married at the convention. At the convention? Yes, and there might have been an office cast member that officiated. Oh, my goodness.
We'll be right back. The holidays are here, and that means it's the most wonderful time of the year to save with Racketon. Use Racketon to stack cashback at your favorite stores on top of holiday sales. That's savings on savings. With Rackaton, you can get cash back on gifts for everyone on your list, from toys for the kids, to kitchen gear, for the person who loves to cook, to electronics for everyone. You can even save on something for yourself. Just shop the stores you love and cashback is automatically added to your account and you can choose to get paid via Interact-E Transfer, PayPal, or check. Join for free today and get a new member bonus after minimum qualifying purchases.
Just go to rackettin.ca. Download the app or install the browser extension. That's R-A-K-U-T-E-N, Terms and Conditions Apply. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. So here we are. It's the holidays. Holidays are a time of traditions. I think when you think of holiday tradition, you're usually thinking about, oh, how do we decorate? How do we exchange gifts? But I wonder if we should add something a new tradition to the holidays, which is the tradition of self-care. Oh, I like that. Right? Yeah. Because it can be a hectic and chaotic time. Absolutely. And also it can be a
lonely time, you know? Yes, and prioritizing the tradition of self-care at the holidays. I feel like we need to add that to the list. I really like that. Well, you know, you're probably having to deal with a lot of folks around the holidays, and therapy can be a way for you to learn positive coping skills, how to reset your boundaries or just set your boundaries and empower yourself to be the best version of yourself. So consider trying better help online therapy in December as a way to close the year with clarity rather than chaos. This December, start a new tradition by taking care of you. Our listeners get 10% off at betterhelp.com slash office ladies.
That's better, h-e-l-p.com slash office ladies. All right, we are back, and Jenna, Cassie and I have quite a story for you all. It was the first time ever at the office convention that two people got married. Mm-hmm. Andy Buckley was the officiate. David Wallace. Uh-huh. Amazing.
So Ryan, a Dwight cosplayer, got married to his fiance, Cora, who is also a cosplayer, and for the wedding, the two of them dressed up as Angela Martin and Dwight Shrewd. Uh-huh. Amazing. And for any of you guys listening who haven't been to conventions, cosplaying is very popular. People dress up as their favorite characters. They go all out. Yeah.
Yeah, and Ryan even reserved a booth, and he set up a Dwight desk, and it had Dwight's little placard and computer phone, a jello mold with a stapler in it. And it was so cool, people could take pictures with him at the desk. And I love talking with him, and here's a clip of him explaining how he ended up getting married at the convention on Sunday morning. So I had plans to get married this year. I actually proposed in front of Weird Al last year. I made him part of the proposal. He kind of helped me out. About a month and a half ago, I reached out to Andy Buckley, not expecting anything.
I just said, hey, would you be interested? Like, it's the last reunion, and I really want to do something special. I'm planning on getting married anyway. It'll be the two-year anniversary of when we met. Do you think you would be interested in marrying us at the reunion? And I expected him to say, you know, I'm really honored. You thought of me. I don't really have the time.
You know, congratulations. I hope you too have a great life. But he got very, very excited about it. Like, he might be as excited about it as we are. And went and got himself ordained. And, yeah, he can't wait for the day just like us. Yeah. It's so amazing.
I'm so excited for you all. Several people have come up to me and, like, you should come talk to him because they're getting married here at the convention. Like, it is a huge buzz this weekend. I mean, we're going to press tons of photos. Are you planning to cosplay as you get married, or will you be yourself? Oh, no. We're going to be Dwight and Angela.
I'm, tonight, I'm using phone board and duct tape to make a makeshift coffin. And that's what we're going to be standing in when we're married, because that's the best you can do on a hard convention floor, you know. Oh, my gosh. I know, right? Wow. It's amazing. And how great that Andy Buckley was just like, I got this. I'm here for you.
I was able to arrive early that. day, and they were doing all their wedding photos right after they got married, and I took pictures with them. Amazing. And they had two best men who were dressed as Moes and Michael Scott. Wow. That is so cool. You got pictures, too?
Can you put them in stories? Yeah, I absolutely will. But a lot of people are dressed up as different office characters. One of the gals that helped work my booth, Betty Jean, she's the sweetest. She told me that she first attended a convention doing cosplay of Pam. Sam, you've done cosplay at conventions, and while I'm slightly afraid to ask this question, would you like to share some of the characters you've dressed up as? I know Big Titty Gandalf is one.
Is that the official name of that one? Yes, Big Titty Gandalf is the name of the character. My personal favorites are I went as Ash from Evil Dead when I met Bruce Campbell. I just met Tim Curry last weekend dressed as Georgie from It with the missing one arm and the bloody raincoat. Other than that, I think those are my favorite. Do you have any plans to go to a convention? Do you have another one coming up?
I do. I'm meeting Robert England, who was Freddie Kruger in January and the Fonds in the same day. So I'm going to try and go as the funds. You're going to meet Henry Winkler? Yeah, I'm going to go. Do you know he's the nicest person on the whole earth? Okay, I do. Years ago, we had a show at Earwolf called Reading Aloud.
It was a reading podcast that Nate Cordry hosted. And Henry Rinkler was the guest. He called in, and the studio shut down, there was a fire alarm that went off. And apparently, when the fire alarm goes off in the building, everything shuts down electricity-wise. So the board shut down, so we lost him. We lost the phone call. I have this great voicemail. It goes, hi, it's Henry Winkler, the actor.
I was the Fonz. He goes, I was just on the call. Like, he gave his whole resume. So you knew who it was. Because he's the nicest, most, like, just humble person on earth. So I'm going to try and put together a Fred. Kruger slash Fawn's outfit. Oh, you have to show us a picture.
Exactly, yeah. This is your challenge now. Exactly. Okay. Are you watching or have you watch Barry? Yes. Yeah, yeah, yeah. He's so good in it.
He's the best. He's the best in that and Arrested Development, too. I love him and Arrested Development. All right. Well, thanks, Sam. Thank you, Sam. Oh, lady, speaking of cosplay, did I send you the photo of the gal who came to my play dressed as Pam?
As Pam, her name was Kelly. I walk out to do the stage door, and there. she is, she was in like a button-down blouse, a pencil skirt, sneakers. It was amazing. I took a photo with her. I will give it to you for stories. I love that, Jenna. You know, Cassie has a great story where a fan told her about meeting an office cast member. Cassie, can you share it? Oh my gosh. It's so unique, and I have a clip, so let's listen to it. I'm Sophia. I'm from New York. I'm Susan. I'm her mom. I'm from Newburgh, New York. Yeah. Love it. Is this your first office convention? This is our second actually
We were at the inaugural So yeah Do you have like a favorite moment From last time you came to the convention I met Creed and it's funny I got my wisdom teeth out the day before So it was like I was like on pain meds And I was like this is awesome
This is a great way to spend But she muscled through it again in here So definitely meeting Creed it was awesome Yeah yeah Can you imagine meeting Creed on painkillers? No No. You can barely believe anything Creed says when you're 100% sober. I know. That's amazing. Cassie, was there anything about the convention that surprised you? Yeah, two things really stood out to me. The first is I was surprised by how many families attended the office convention together. It was so sweet. Yeah, there were so many families. I'm talking like moms, dads, little kids, teenage kids, and it was really sweet to see them all there. Angela, wasn't your family at the convention?
They did. So Josh and the kids stopped by. We made this sort of a family trip to New York and then we went on to Iceland. Yeah. But they did come for half a day and they were there for the Q&A panel. What did they think of all of it? It was wild. I think people, first of all, when they saw them walk in, people like clapped and they were like, oh, it's so glad you're here, you know. And so I think they really felt the warmth and love of the office fandom for the cast and the crew. And I think it was really special for. for them. I think it was also kind of that thing where it's like, well, that's just my mom. What's going on? Yeah, you know, my kids, they don't see that kind of like fandom interaction very often. And so I think they were a little bit like, whoa, like when that stage door would open and people were cheering for their mom. Yeah. You know? I know. You don't get that every day. Like when you're like, all right, it's dinner. Who's coming down and helps us at the table? They're not like,
B'bib! Exactly. Well, Cassie, I saw you talk. talking to a few of the families that I got to meet. Can you share with us about that? Oh, my gosh. Yeah, there are so many families, and I love talking with all of them. I just want to share a couple. Here's a clip of Max, Emily, Ella, and their parents, Amy and Mike from New Hampshire. My name is Max, and I'm from Summer's Worth, New Hampshire.
New Hampshire. What's your name? Emmy. Emmy. And I'm Ella. Ella. And are you the parents? Yeah.
Amy. Mike. Great. And I take it, you all love the office? Yes. I've been raised on it. Yeah. Do you all have like a favorite episode?
I really like the one where Dwight almost burns down the building with a fire drill. I saw you have office tattoos. Are you the only one in the family with office tattoos? Yes. Sure is. Can you let the podcast know what your office tattoos are? Yep. So I've got one prison mic.
On one calf, and on the other calf is Dwight as Jim. Wow, that's amazing. You know, speaking of families, I have a share about a dad and his daughters who listened to office ladies. So I didn't get to meet the dad, but the daughters were at the stage door, and they were so sweet. They told me the sweet story, and I asked if they would say it again, if I could record it. Here's what they said. Okay, ladies, say your name. Delaney
Bridget You have to now tell the Office Ladies listeners and Angela what you just told me because it's the cutest thing in the whole world
My dad and I listen to the Office Ladies podcast whenever we're in the car together His name is Brad and he and the rest of my family Carter and my mom
Stacy were the biggest fan It's on repeat in our house all the time I love you And you have to say Why are you here tonight in Chicago seeing this play
We're here because you bought us tickets to come and see it, and it was amazing. Your dad bought you tickets and was like, ladies, go see this show. Thank you. What's your dad's name? Brad. Brad, thank you. Isn't that so sweet? She said her dad heard about the play on the podcast, and he said,
Girls, you got to go see it, and he got them tickets. That is so sweet. This is Katie and Chris. Exactly. It's so, I just love it. I love the show bringing families together and the podcast. Cassie, any more? Yeah, I'll share one more.
I really enjoyed talking to this family, Elise, Bridget, and Anderson from South Carolina and Georgia. I am Elise Scarborough, and I'm from Charleston, South Carolina. Bridget Scarborough, Savannah, Georgia. Anderson Scarborough, Savannah, Georgia. Love it. And what are you wearing? I am a bear. I am a beat.
and I am Battlestar Galactica. Love it, love it. Is this your first office convention? Yes. And what does the office mean to you? Everything. Uh-huh. I think I watch it every single day.
It's like what I fall asleep to, I know if I put the office on, it's time for bed. It just brings us so much joy. We like to watch it when we all hang out together. We're watching it this morning getting ready. It's just really... It gives us... Yeah, it's familiar. I'm not going to lie.
I did not like the office for the longest time. I did not like it. Because them two, especially at least, she would always throw it on in the car during making dinner. It was always on. And I'd be like, y'all, it's not even that funny. And then I think, like, I don't know, I caught like an episode or two. And I was like, dang, this is actually really funny. I watched through the whole season.
And I remember sitting in my mom's house watching the finale at like three in the morning because I just had to finish it that night. And when Steve Carell came back, and I cried, I bawled my eyes out, dog. I cried so bad. It was such an amazing finale. And I always say that if aliens would have ever come down and they were like, yo, give us a TV show to watch it, describe America. I think the office would be like the perfect thing. Like, that's the show that would describe America as a whole.
Get them called it dispedia. Yeah. Can I tell you what I love about Anderson? Anderson went from turn off that show, get it out of my life, to being dressed as Battlestar Galactica in a three-person outfit at an office convention. Right. That is a journey that he has gone on. Also, to say, okay, aliens, this is what our gift to you, now you understand our world. That was awesome.
Cassie, you said there was one other thing that really surprised you. What was it? Yeah. I kept asking fans what their favorite office episode was. was, and so many fans kept saying this one episode, and I wouldn't have ever guessed it. Do you guys want to try to guess? Okay, so it's something I wouldn't guess because my first instinct would be like dinner party or booze cruise or something.
So this is one I wouldn't guess. Oh, I'm thinking. I'm thinking, too. Goodbye, Michael is my guess. I'll go season one and I'll say Diversity Day. Oh, no. Max actually hinted at it. It's stress relief.
Stress relief. People love stress relief. Because of that cold open? Yeah. Yeah, with the fire, safe bandit. We should watch the superfan version of stress relief. Sure. Yeah.
Maybe we should if it's everybody's favorite. I know. I wonder what new little nuggets are in that one. I wonder. We might have to hit up David Rogers. I've noticed you've started calling Dave Rogers David Rogers. Is this his preferred name now? No, I think it's because I have a brother-in-law named David,
who I called Dave constantly, and then sort of heard my sister-in-law and some of his family always say David. And then I said to Josh, is he Dave or David? And then he was like, he's Dave. I'm like, okay, fine. And then his sister was like, no, he's David. Oh. But is Dave Rogers now, David?
I don't know. And I think I have this default now where I'm like, I'm going to say both. I'm going to do 50-50. Sometimes I'm going to say Dave. Sometimes I'm going to say David. I was just checking. I'm covering all my bases. Well, the next time we have lunch with him, maybe we should ask.
Okay. Well, Angela, you mentioned that you met people from all over the world. I'm curious, who traveled the furthest? Do we know to the convention? I remember who I talked to, and I can let Adam answer. Oh. Oh, okay. Okay.
Adam from England. Yeah. Oh, did you travel all the way to be here today? Yeah, just for this. Oh my gosh. I've seen pictures of the past ones and I thought, oh, I've got, I wish I could go. And then this is the last one, so yeah, I had to do it. Yeah, it's amazing.
Yeah. Awesome. Yeah. Now you said you listen to the podcast. Do you have like a favorite episode or a moment from the podcast? I really enjoyed one of the latest ones with Lucy Davis, obviously, because of the sort of British connection as well. Yeah. That was fascinating. Yeah, really good. Yeah. Okay, I remember Adam. So I met Adam and we were talking about the podcast and he said one of the things, you know, that was always hard for him is if we had to skip a week, if we were going in order and we had to skip a week because it was like Christmas break or whatever.
Oh, and we left him hanging. Yeah. It was like a two-part episode. Yes, especially if it was a two-part episode. And I told him, I was like, you're going to love Monday second drinks because it's, is the entire show, the whole rewatch in order. We're not going to miss one. And we're adding new information at the top. Anything we missed. So you're going to get a little more stuff at the top. But I was like, don't you worry, Adam. It's going to be in order. I'm glad you mentioned the second drinks because I had a couple people ask me what they were. Like they were confused by it. And it's been going on for almost two years now. And I guess for anyone who missed it, it's our original rewatch, but with about 10 minutes of new information at the top. So you can just listen to the 10 minutes if you want, or if you want to listen to that and then keep going, you can
revisit all of our Office Ladies episodes in order with no breaks, like you said. Yeah, especially because when we first started the rewatch, there was a lot of information that we gathered as we went. We found more scripts. We found the candy bag alts. We found outlines. We had writers assistants, writers, directors, give us a whole bunch of information. So if we missed anything, now is our chance with the second drinks to include all that. I'm also going back to our archive fan mailbags for all of those episodes, and I'm pulling extra questions or things that people are telling us we missed or got wrong. So if you wrote us like five years ago, you might hear yourself on a second drink.
Yeah. To the guy that wrote me that we missed a Daryl storyline, you're going to hear it. Well, I had a lot of people share that they traveled to see the play. It just warmed my heart. I would go out to the stage door and people would literally have their luggage with them. Like they came right off the train or, you know, right from the airport. Someone told me they traveled solo from Singapore. Wow.
There was someone from Brazil, someone from Argentina. And then just lots of people from all around the country. And that was really moving to me that people came out to support the play. And my favorite was when there was like a group of people who had all traveled together or met up. I know a lot of people coordinated that on our Facebook fan page. I just loved seeing how office ladies brought people together. And then they went on these creative adventures. Yeah. You know, like going to the convention together, coming to see the play. And there was one group. They called themselves, oh my gosh, what were they called? Oh, they called themselves
the culture club. It was like their version of a finer things club. And they go out and they go see art or plays. And so thank you to the culture club for coming to see Ashland Avenue. It is really, you know, special, though, the Office Ladies' Facebook fan page that is moderated by Nikki and all of these wonderful people that have met. Oh, Nikki came to Ashland Avenue. Yeah, I saw your picture. Yes. Yeah. And, you know, it is a really wonderful community. And a lot of people have made friendships and I think lasting friendships through this group. And Cassie, you said you talked to some office ladies folks, too. Yeah. Oh, my goodness. I met so many Office Ladies fans. I really want to share this clip from Richard and Rachel from South Carolina.
You have to hear where Rachel listens to Office Ladies. Okay. I'm Richard and this is Rachel. We're from South Carolina. Awesome. And what are you wearing? So we're wearing our Michael Scott, Stunder Mithlin, Scranton, Meredith, Homer, Memorial, Celebrity, Rabies, Awareness, Pro-Am, run for, fun run, raise for the cure. It's hard to read upside down. They hung up. No, Michael came over that name. They need to hear the entire name. What does the office mean to you? Some of the last good television, I think.
I mean, it's just, it's excellent television, and it's a way that we unwind, like, every day, and it's our time to just relax. Yeah, after a really stressful day, we've got kids, we've got a farm, we've got our jobs. It's nice to just get together today, snuggle up in bed, the office. It helps put us to sleep every night. It's such great riding. It's so, it's just so
good. Half of our goats are named after the office characters. Oh my gosh. We breed goats and one of our bucks is named Michael Scott. And so we have a lot of Scott's tauts. When you said farm, I was just like, oh, they're referring to their kids, but no, you have a literal farm with goats. That's so cool. I'm usually listening to office ladies when I'm bush hogging the fields. Like, that is how I drown out the tractor noise is I listen to office ladies and look at my goats named after the office characters. Rachel, I love it.
I hope right now that's happening. I hope we're in your ear right now. I know, Rachel, I keep telling Josh, I want one of those little mini goats. Oh, you want one of Scott's tots. I do. I said that on the Today Show when we were on for our cookbook.
At the end, they were like, oh, Angela, do you have like cats in real life? And I was like, we have cats, we have dogs. I was like, I'd have more animals. if Josh would let me, like, I want a goat. And you could have heard record scratch. And someone goes, a goat? How delightful? Something like that.
And I was like, oh, no, that'll be the thing that haunts me. And sure enough, my family was like, you won't goats. Well, listen, why don't we take a break? And when we come back, we're just going to keep chatting about our convention and stage door adventures. This Cyber Monday, discover the smart way to scent your home with Pura. Enjoy 30% off curated sets, including the sleek Pura 4 and Pura Plus diffusers. Fill your space with premium fragrance, control your scent from anywhere,
and set custom schedules for every mood. It's the easiest way to upgrade your home for less. Don't miss your chance to save 30% only at Pura.com for a limited time. All right, we're back. And I don't know why I didn't mention this earlier, but there was a huge group of people one night at the stage door. They called themselves the convention people. They were like, we're the convention people. They had all been at the convention together, and then they all came out to Chicago. And lady, that is the group that was holding your cookbook in the reel that I posted
on Instagram back in October for your book launch. Oh, that was so sweet. They were so sweet. I had your cookbook in my backpack because I was flipping. through the recipes at intermission. And I was like, oh, this is the perfect crowd. And one of the things they told me, they were so sweet. They were like, Jackie DeBotton says hi. Jim McDermott says hi. Because Jim McDermott was at the convention. Yes. He was our set dresser on the office. Yes. So, you know, in the years past, several of our crew members have been able to attend the convention and share their experience. And it was so great to see Jim. I was able to chat with him one morning. And Cassie, you got to talk to him too, right? Yeah. So when I wasn't in Angela's line,
I went around and I talked to different cast members and I talked to Jim as well. So here's a great clip of him describing his job and some of the challenges he had working on the show. Do you want to describe your job for the fans? Me, to set that career, go to production. We get the script early, read it, break it down, determine how much manpower we need, truck power, how much the rentals would be for each set and how much purchases we'd have to budget that in and we always came within a thousand dollars so we did a pretty good job and there were some pretty big sets and everybody thought yeah you got the easiest job in town all you got into the office it's like no we got the new york
office we had we had oscars apart we had games apart but we had everything you know the warehouse set was huge and then we had all the other district offices Nashua and all these other ones so i mean you know we went into empty office buildings recreated those and made all kinds of graphics and everything, you know, the Dundra Mifty graphics, and it was just such a fun thing to do. Do you have, like, a favorite set that you created? Well, this was behind Jenna's desk. Hi, Jenna. I'll show you. It was this right here. This is a certificate of participation with James' name on it. Oh, yeah, it's right behind. If you hear this screaming, it's a pretzel eating contest. Leslie David Baker just got on stage.
It's great. Do you have an office episode that you're like, this one was a pain in my butt to work on? I think the New York corporate office when we first did it, it was kind of tricky, but it was mostly hallway in a couple, and a lobby. It wasn't so bad. We put a lot of detail into Gabe's apartment, and that was a really nice set. Yeah, that was a good one. That's when Dwight picked up the baby and it stopped crying in real life. The baby stopped crying.
It was a good one take, man. Yeah. And then that was a real nice set. And Oscars, we put a lot of thought in the Oscars apartment. We actually had a bathroom in there that we did a nice job, but they never shot in the bathroom. Oh, no. Yeah.
But they were really good people to us. I mean, everybody was cool to work with. All the actors were really nice. That's great. Last question. So you go in and you create the set when they're actually shooting. Do you stay on set during the shoot? He's called an on-set dresser.
He stays with the camera. But we come in in the morning, there earlier and the guys clean all the sets they vacuum and dust and clean up everything but you know we'll leave all stanley's crossword puzzles on his desk and make sure creed has this solitary game up and i have a guy that comes in and cleans the computers every week an IT guy and uh we had live plants in there so there's nothing fake so i got the order for the uh boisey paper and they gave us free script paper every month so probably saved them millions of dollars on paper alone and then we would take the empty boxes and put them in the warehouse set on pallets.
Oh, yeah. So all those boxes in the warehouse set were empty. Whoa. Yeah. When they had to go through something and load up, we put little sandbags in them. Oh. Full of sand. So they dropped it.
It sounded like it was heavy. Okay. And then the props, all the props we got, like, remember the froggy sticker next to Dwight's stand? I put that on there. Oh. So we had, we got in touch. We were trying to figure out how to use things from Scranton.
So I suggested we call Mari Pottis is her name. She's the Chamber of Commerce President. And we're like, can we get some local Scranton goods from your local businesses? Yeah. But they got to sign off. We thought we'd get like three or four boxes. We got ten pallets of stuff.
Oh, my God. Yeah. Tons of stuff. Yeah. That's amazing. Yeah. So we got to, we used a lot of it. You know, refrigerator had all kinds of menus on it.
Alferado's pizzas are real pizzeria. Yeah. Yeah. So I got, I ended up meeting a lot of people that are friends with in Scranton. So I'm going to go to the 5K next year. Yeah. I want to go. I wish Jenna was here.
I hope Jenna's doing okay. Hi, Jenna. Yeah, she's doing okay. She's working on a play in Chicago now. Oh, that's great. I love that detail that he shared about the pallets in the warehouse, that we got all that free paper that we used to print our scripts every week, and then they just filled them with sandbags.
I had no idea. All those boxes were empty. Yeah, I just assumed all those were actually filled with paper, I guess, because they were heavy. Well, I remember Oscar's apartment with such detail. I took a bunch of pictures of it because I was doing a home renovation. And I was like, you guys, this is so beautiful. And I didn't realize they didn't do a single scene in the bathroom.
You know, they built a whole bathroom set for Ashland Avenue because our characters walk in there from time to time. But only like this tiny sliver of the audience could see it. It was literally like 12 seats could see into the bathroom. But they built a whole bathroom. I was really appreciative of it because otherwise I would have been like walking backstage and just kind of pretending I was in a bathroom, but I could stand in a real bathroom. That's cool. I did not see the bathroom set.
No, no, no, no, literally 12 people. Like our director, Susan Booth, she'd always be like, okay, Jenna, exit to the bathroom. 12 people will get to see what you're doing in there. So don't forget, you got to keep acting while you're in there. Wow. Yeah. That's so cool. Oh, and Jim gave me something to give to you to.
Oh, he did? What? Yeah. So he gave me the day. daily call sheet for the pilot. Oh, wow. Wow. And it's like the, oh my goodness. You know what? I have this as a digital thing. All right. Yeah, so this is the call sheet for, it says day 2.5 of 5.5. So day two of the pilot. Here's what it says under set dressing. It says that they're going to need a coat rack, a Homer Simpson doll, an office plant, and a Billy Bass Fisher. on the wall. I didn't realize the Billy Bass Fish went that far back. It does, I guess.
All right. Well, listen, since we're giving gifts, I have stuff that people gave me at the stage door for all of you. Angela, I'm going to start with you. Jackie gifted us the cutest Chicago-inspired sweatshirts. She makes these on her Etsy shop. It's called Jacqueline Louise, please. She made you a Chicago deep dish pizza sweatshirt. Oh, deep dish pizza sounds really good right now. She made me a Chicago hot dog. I loved the Chicago hot dogs when I was there, so I'm very excited that she gave me the hot dog one. And in her note, she said, quote, I knew not to give you the deep dish one because nothing compares to emo's. So there you go, lady. Also, Stephanie C made us each keychains. So here's the story. She told you. She told you.
told me that she had sent some to us way back when we were at Earwolf. She asked me if we got them. She said it was around the time we were transitioning and she was worried they got lost in the move. So she was hand delivering new ones to us. Stephanie, I have to tell you something when I finally unwrapped these, we did get your first son of keychains. And now we all have two keychains from you. Yay. And we love them. Mine has a little engraved quote on it that says what one man can do, another can do. I love it. Mine says, lady, thanks for all the laughs. I hope to meet you in real life someday, so you will chat me up like we're old friends. Oh, I love it. That's so great. I also got some gifts from Ben and Sarah. They have a company called Just Be. That's B-E. And they gifted,
Angela, you, I have a candle. It smells so good. And Sam and Cassie, you each get a little diffuser. One of them is white birch, and one of them is peony and mahogany. Do you guys have a choice? Cassie, which one do you want? I'll go white birch. Sorry, Sam. She's closest to the mic, Sam. She gets to pick.
Oh, it smells so good. And I also have some treats. I had to bring in some Garrett's popcorn. For all of us, you guys know about Garrett's popcorn, right? No. No. What? We don't.
I'm not making it up. Oh, my gosh. Yeah, I know Garrett's popcorn. popcorn. I love Garrett's popcorn. What? Thank you. It is the perfect mixture of sweet and salty. Yes, this is it. Thank you. Thank you. My pleasure. Jenna feels so validated. Cassie and I were like, nope. Okay, they're famous for their like caramel corn, their cheese popcorn, their regular popcorn, but the Chicago mix is where you mix the cheese and the caramel together. What? That's the one that I became slightly obsessed with, and that's one
I brought back for you guys. Jeez and care. I can't wait to try. Okay. Don't worry. Okay. Also, this gal from Germany brought us all German chocolates. She brought them all the way to Chicago, but she didn't sign her name on the card.
But here's what she did right. Quote, Dear Office Ladies' team, you've been good this year. So German Christmas came early, signed Belshnichel, who, by the way, is not a thing in Germany, L-O-L. All right. Well, I have a few things I wanted to share, too. First of all, from the convention, I wanted to read a card that we got in its address to Angela, Jenna, Cassie, and Sam.
And it's from Rachel N. And here's what she had to say. Angela Jenna, Sam and Cassie, thank you all for the Office Ladies' podcast. You're creating such a fun and interesting show that brightens up my day as well as countless others. I originally started listening because I'm a big fan of the office, plus a huge sucker for anything behind the scenes. I started off a fan of the show and have since become an even bigger fan of you all.
It's so cool getting to hear from so many of the cast and crew members and getting to know you all as human beings in such a relaxed and down-to-earth manner. This podcast has brought the show home. It's so evident how much of a family you all are. Your on-screen chemistry was always incredible, but your real-life chemistry is refreshing. I know nothing about creating a podcast, but there has to be so much work going into it from all of you. Thank you for putting in the time and energy as well as your hearts and souls. Listening always boosts my mood. Rachel.
Thanks, Rachel. Is that a great card? Yeah, that's really sweet. I just love that. I got a lot of cards and notes from people as well, and it was really sweet. They would say, I didn't want to forget what I wanted to tell you. I read them all and they just, they were really touching. Yeah.
Well, we also got a lot of gifts at the convention. I'm going to list a few, like these napkins with stitching that say, Cassie sass. What? What's up, Sam? You got some Sam sass. And then also, Jenna, Sarah from Gig Harbor, Washington made us the most adorable crochet dolls of our The Office characters. She also said if she were asked the call sheet questions, her answer for, tell us a place you've been to that you absolutely loved. She would tell us to go to Monteverde in Costa Rica. She said there is a hummingbird gallery with dozens of feeders and hundreds of hummingbirds gather there. I looked at it. I looked at it. up and oh my God, I want to go. Wow. Great. And then from my cookbook tour, I have to share with you, lady, I met a gal named Leah. She's so talented, and she made us these gorgeous necklaces. On her card, she said, and I quote, office ladies has been my happy place for years. Is that so sweet? Yes. I also have lots of other gifts and cards from the convention, and I have a whole box for you, Jenna. Oh, thank you. Thank you. Everybody. I absolutely.
loved my stage door meet and greets. It sounds like you guys had a great time at the convention and Angela on your cookbook tour. Well, before we wrap up here, I want to give a few shoutouts. We all do to everyone we met at the convention. It's such a big event. And it really wouldn't be possible without the amazing people that work and volunteer at it. So special shout out to them, to the people at my booth, Kat and Betty Jean, to Arnold for organizing the convention. And to Randy, She sent me so many pictures. Thank you, Randy. Yeah, everyone was so cool and kind.
And I actually interviewed Betty Jean, who Angela mentioned earlier. She used to cosplay as Pam. Here's her sharing her experience as volunteer. My name is Betty Jean. I'm from Brooklyn, New York. Great. And how long have you been volunteering for the office convention? This is my second year of volunteering.
I've attended all for the first two I was cosplay as Pam. And then I just got a glimpse of all of the, love and labor that goes into the convention behind the scenes, and I was delighted to find out that they were open for volunteers. So it's been the greatest volunteer gig of my life. That's awesome. So what is it like being a volunteer? I mean, it really boils down to going where you're needed. You never know what's going to happen from you might get placed handling admissions. You might be dealing with merchandise. You might be welcoming vendors. You might be a celebrity handler and helping, you know, hold space for really amazing interactions between fans
and the casting crew that they came to meet. So you never know, there's never a dull moment, but I've gotten so many stories out of this. I'm a minister by trade, so I'm constantly writing stories and discernments, including about humor affecting our life. And I can't even believe just the thousands of stories that I've gotten to hear at this convention,
fans pouring their heart out to the casting crew themselves about how the show has changed their lives, how it's had, you know, a decades-long impact on them. So this is the stuff I live for. And now being able to pay it forward for other fans and help create the space. It's amazing. Oh, isn't that special? I love what she said about collecting stories as a minister.
I think that's so cool. I just love that she volunteers. Did you know that theater ushers are also volunteers? No, I didn't know that. Yes. Most theater ushers, that's a volunteer thing. And they do that in exchange for getting to see the plays and musicals for free. I would have done that for sure. Yeah, so everybody, be nice to your ushers. Yeah, they're volunteering.
Exactly. And put your phones away. Well, yeah. So that they don't have to crack down. For sure. Well, before we go, Cassie, I know there was one last thing that you wanted to share with us. And I'm actually so curious about it. You hinted at it.
Yeah. About it to me. So go ahead. It was like my favorite question that I always asked at the end of every interview. and it was Scott's Tots. Do you watch it or skip it? So many people tell me they skip it. Oh, we did such a great breakdown of it too with B.J. NoFack. I know. I know.
Well, what did people say? Yeah, so all of the responses were so different. So I made like a little compilation and here it is. Scott's Tots, do you watch it or skip it? It's the only episode I skip. I definitely watch it. It's like one of the funniest episodes. How could you not watch it?
You know, it completely depends on the mood, but I'm going to say skip. Sometimes I skip it, but other times I don't, because Stanley's reaction to that whole thing is just beyond. It's so funny. Oh, no, I watch. That is a painful episode to watch. It is hard to watch. It is hard to watch. I watch it, but I cringe.
And you? Yeah, I watch it. Watch it. You never skip an episode. Even if you're, like, cringing, you're like, oh, Michael, why? Oh, I watch it. I know, yeah, there's a cringe factor for sure, but it's like, you know, that's just part of it. Both. I watch it and skip it. Depends on your mood. It's on the day, yep.
I definitely watch it. It's like one of the funniest episodes. How could you not watch it? In between. In between, depends on the mood. Watch it, but it's cringy. I watch it and I laugh. I think it's pretty funny. I watch everything. You can't be a fan and skip anything. That's just how it is. You got to get through it. Watch, obviously, in my Scott's T-Tot's T-shirt. Oh, love it. So it sounds like more watchets than skips it.
I think I relate more to the people that are like, it depends on the day. Well, a big thank you to everyone who showed up to meet us and shared with us about their love of the office and office ladies. I really love and treasure this community of folks so much. Yeah, thank you. And thank you, Jim McDermott, for talking to Cassie. and sharing about your experience of working as a set dresser and just hello right back at you. And also, thank you to everyone who waited at the stage door after Ashland Avenue. You were all so polite and patient and kind when I would go to take a selfie with someone,
all the other people they would like duck down and get out of the way to make it a good. It was like, it's what you're talking about. It's just like a community of good folks. It was an honor to speak with all of you. So thank you. and in fact, as a way to say thank you for all of your support, Angela and I want to do an office ladies merch giveaway. Angela, tell everybody how it's going to work. Yes, we appreciate you all so much, and we thought it'd be really fun to start doing some merch giveaways.
Our first one is going to be a holiday merch box dropping in December. We're going to give away five boxes of goodies. So five different people are going to get one of these merch giveaway boxes. That's right. We're going to announce it on our Instagram, Office Ladies' Pod, when it goes live. So be on the lookout for all the details there. Well, there you go. That is our fan convention and stage door episode. Thank you, Cassie, for compiling all those audio clips and traveling with me to New Jersey. Oh, my goodness. We'll always have New Jersey, Cassie. We'll always have New Jersey. All right, you guys, have a great week. See you later. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.